такий порядок денний Нам не потрібен
чому да тому що там нема ключових питань
Я подавав ще Минулого року демобілізація
після 18 місяців служби Де цей
законопроект Скільки можна чекати нам
подає уряд який До речі втік До нас
прийшов уряд тільки заспівати гімн До
побачення в Верховній Раді хор верьвки
своє заспівав Ми пішли де уряд чого його
немає вносить нам закон проект про
мобілізацію демобілізацію де навіть
термін служби в 36 місяців і те реально
прибирає а допоки барін не дозволить
піти додому ще має бути окреме рішення
ставки де законопроект про демобілізацію
немає де законопроект про демобілізацію
обмежено придатних немає де законопроект
про демобілізацію інвалідів немає де
законопроекти які потрібні сьогодні
війську Де мій законопроект про ротації
ну не може такого бути що люди деякі
військовослужбовці більше двох років
сьогодні на нулі більше тому що були
підрозділи які воювали на Донбасі ще до
24 лютого і їх жодного разу не відвели
де законопроект про ротацію немає де всі
важливі законопроекти замість цього
чергові затвердження ратифікації заяв
звернень бла-бла-бла бла-бла-бла де
повернення тридцятки скоро Рік як ми тут
проголосували До сих пір де питання
постанови цабеля ганебної якою
заблокували тоді повернення тридцятки і
з тих пір з квітня місяця людям не
виплачують де всі ті закони які потрібні
сьогодні де підняття дитячих які ганебні
і так далі друзі така Верховна Рада з
таким порядком денним українському
народу не потрібна